ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi cucineremo con la
lavastoviglie
da una parte abbiamo i nostri
ingredienti dall'altra parte abbiamo un
altro tipo di ingredienti oggi faremo un
qualcosa che sta andando un sacco di
moda ultimamente online un qualcosa che
ci avete consigliato in tanti e che
sinceramente non reputavo possibile
bando alle ciance oggi noi i nostri ci
facciamo il forno ogni lavaggio della
lavastoviglie infatti consuma calore e
acqua che sono tutti degli elementi che
in realtà possono aiutarti non solo a
lavare i tuoi piatti ma allo stesso
tempo la cena il pranzo la colazione
partiamo con ingredienti per fare il
pollo in lavastoviglie avremo bisogno di
sette di pollo sottilissime prosciutto
crudo un peperone peperone dolcissimo un
pomodoro maturo salvia rosmarino pepe
nero salonio e tanta voglia di cucinare
lavare mi raccomando se vorrete provare
questo esperimento al di là di tag arni
su instagram guglielmo scilla fatelo
quando lavate qualcosa perché altrimenti
consumate acqua e energia inutilmente ed
è per questo che vogliamo darvi il buon
esempio con tutte questa feccia da
infilare all'interno della mia lavatrice
che non la vedrei c minuscola quindi non
so cantare o per riuscire a tirarsi ma
sull'unico che sbaglia lavatrice e
lavastoviglie per me sono la stessa cosa
con cui sono curioso di vedere mai
proceduto come si caricano la nostra
vita di faccio vedere intanto io
caricola stoviglie che è la cosa più
divertente che si possa fare
adoro e tra parentesi non so voi io odio
quando qualcun altro una carica perché
non la fa come dico io non credo dubito
questo qualcosa ma non dovrai parte va
sicuramente nato uccisione la voglio
fare amare
no perché c'è il piacere dei miei coli
abbiamo caricato la lavastoviglie non
siamo riusciti a infilare proprio tutto
ma un po di una bar ma son tenuta fuori
qualora avessi un languorino più tardi
no ma molti minuti doveva perdere perché
o meno 40 minuti è una cottura lenta
simile a quella al vapore quindi in
realtà sarà leggerissimo perché sarà
come non aver mangiato
per prima cosa bisogna con un batticarne
prendere queste fettine e renderle
ancora più sottili io non ho matti carli
quindi ho trovato qualcosa di
alternativo dice forse serve qualcosa di
più duro
la melanzana non funziona la capitana
borracce da miss angola
se questa è ottima in una melodia reale
nota
questa è una nota amara per qualsiasi
chef sta guardando questo video
a questo punto fetta di prosciutto crudo
sopra prenderà salvia il rosmarino e
andate a tritare finemente succedendo
questo ragazzi durante questa notte
vogliono imparare il kung fu pollo fetta
di prosciutto un pochino di spezie del
pepe del timo arrotoliamo
sul sito che è petit chef suggeriscono
di utilizzare degli stuzzicadenti io
sinceramente non vorrei nulla che possa
formare i miei sacchetti quindi
utilizzano dello spago da un qualcosa di
estremamente fallico di nuovo ripetiamo
ti consiglio di tagliarmi dello spago
già in quanto te li devo fare lunghi più
o meno va bene come il tuo bene non così
corti col mazza grazie jam è in realtà è
un po meno però a cercare di prenderli
tipo profondi come il mio ok vieni un
attimo anche in trasferta
ecco tutto tuo alla fine pero dovuto
andare io ma vedi quanti che eletti
sasso stavo se mangiamo i piedi destato
oltre al pollo in lavastoviglie fine di
vero mangerai posso essere onesto con
voi io sento un fallimento dietro
l'angolo ma proprio di quelli cocenti
dimensioni penn enrico va bene sì perché
molto sottile così almeno cambiano
proprio zoomare perché sì ecco nel mio
vabbè manca solo di mira a questo punto
[Risate]
legando questo non l'hai fatto
secondo me no
allora abbiamo preparato gli involtini
passiamo al suddetto prendiamo il
peperone tagliamo a metà ancora ancora
sembrano ti poni i cavalieri del signore
degli anelli o è vero andiamo a
tagliarli e affari tipo una parlata via
l'anima mischiamo
olio appena sale 3 andando velocissimi
oggi c'è una certa maestria in cucina
fondamentale dicono di prendere o il
baratto di quelli che sigillano
ermeticamente
oppure i sacchetti che metti il
sottovuoto non avevamo né l'uno né
l'altro quindi abbiamo preso delle
bellissime buste da frigo in ognuna
metterò 2 involtini aggiungerà un terzo
del composto che ho creato da questo
punto cercando di buttare fuori più aria
possibile che facendolo girare su se
stesso sigillerà picco non è siciliano
non ha originato lo sai benissimo
andiamo avanti in questi mesi girato
rientra tutto lo schifo ricoperte doppio
strato dopo strato lo sa fare una
considerazione tornando indietro andrei
a recuperare online dei vasetti perché
così un po un controsenso troppa
plastica si spreca abbiamo cercato di
creare il più possibile un sottovuoto li
sfidiamo dentro vediamo che cosa succede
e pregate per noi e mi nave succede a
questo questo e questo sempre qua sotto
chiudiamo mettiamo il 70 gradi
chiudiamo
e morara io veramente non ho idea alcune
di cosa possa succedere là dentro
aspettiamo abbiamo appena aperto
lavastoviglie il pollo non è ancora
cotto inizio a temere che sia perché il
vasetto la busta non fossero quelli
giusti e quindi ci stanno troppi strati
che le separano dal calore ora
ricaricavano con un pochino di roba che
c'era avanzate e facciamo andare di
nuovo in forno piazziamo questo qua
questa ten fino qui a the thing fino qua
chiudiamo facciamo andare un'altra
stoviglie questa qui però più bassa la
facciamo vediamo dove andiamo
lo scopriremo allora abbiamo finito o a
bada prenderli
mi sembra che non sia entrato nemmeno un
goccio d'acqua dentro che ora facciamo
un'analisi più accurata
prendiamo anche gli altri posso dirti
qual è l'unico modo per scoprirlo gianni
passare all'assaggio l'aspetto veramente
bottino a mi aspetto è abbastanza
terrificante in questo preciso momento
storico può essere anche un involtino
cesta broda che esce fuori bisognerà
capire se effettivamente acqua di scolo
4 è anemico pallido non benissimo
quattro e mezzo quattro meno commodore e
salvatore buono l'odore gradevole si
sente tutto odori fette meno secondo me
7 se lo merita buono delicato
leggermente noioso a me le ricette molto
dietetiche queste cose superlight
uccidono un po devo esser sincero 6
procediamo all'assaggio che mi
terrorizza ragazze cotto per essere un
cibo preso e buttato in una
lavastoviglie il risultato è
sorprendente una faccia c'è stato un
addio succosissimo 76 e mezzo
allora a una perplessità non riesco a
capire bene c'è un po di detersivo temo
sia sabbia
ecco svelato l'arcano sapore sette e
mezzo compiti di 8 e bassi di sette voto
globale sei e mezzo sei più sei meno
verso infamia e senza lode per ragazzi
scriveteci qua sotto altri metodi di
cottura che siamo curiosissimi lama
voglia di marley quanto pagherei per
questo piatto preferire non pagare
andare alla vari piatti al ristorante no
perché rischio che mentre loro non lo
ritrovo con l'ordine rei queste senza
costi
vorrei che rinasce nella nostri figli
beh però me lo immagino fatto con gli
scarti del pollo pagherei pagherei 6
euro e 56 euro
sono un estimatore di questa nuova
tecnica la tota dai fatto il pumpkins
che una cacata questo è un piatto
semplice e gradevole con una tecnica di
cottura rivoluzionaria quindi perché il
semplice non può essere buono è lo
strano deve essere buono chi sparla
ragazzi siamo creati rapidi questo video
come sempre fatemi sapere sono sbagliato
qualcosa perché non sono sicuro di
essere riuscito a beccare esattamente
tutti i procedimenti in maniera corretta
detto ciò come sempre iscriviti a questo
canale attivate la campagna delle
notifiche e fateci sapere quali sono
altri piatti che vorreste vedere
all'interno di questo format continuato
a mandare gli sfondi che vedete durante
cucina buttata
metteteci un bel pollice in su per il io
vi mando un bacio ci vediamo giovedì con
un altro video alle 12 ciao